bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur arte france alors le fdc
toujours déterminés ils dénoncent ce
qu'ils appellent les velléités d'alpha
condé de rester président à vie quelle
est votre position là dessus le
président à vie c'est pas 24 un
troisième mandat même s'ils ne s'est pas
encore exprimé clairement sur cette
possibilité
les signes sont de plus en plus clair en
ce moment la découvrance originale du
parti rpg son parti qui sont être
organisées à travers le pays et ce qui
en ressort c'est que les militants qui
sont de lui pendant ces conventions sont
en train de porter ferland président
alpha condé pour un troisième mandat
complètement immature en continu porté
son choix sur lui
il ya aussi une volonté manifeste de la
part du pouvoir de se maintenir coûte
que coûte
quelles que soient les conséquences on
remplace donc on ne sait pas encore si
c'est pour le présent le flacon des pour
après et le mandat pour quelqu'un
d'autre nom que quelque chose est sûre
le pouvoir qui est là actuellement qui
l'installé veut conserver pouvoir ça
c'est sympa alors plusieurs membres du
fn blessés ont été interpellés ils sont
en détention il ya cinq ou yaya diallo
également oumar sylla
amnesty international demande leur
libération immédiate
qu'amnesty international s'en mêle est
ce que ça peut faire bouger les choses
selon vous non non ça fera pas bouger
les choses je passe que pauline
extrêmement simple le pouvoir actuel a
démontré bien avant le référendum du 22
mars dernier qui n'était plus du tout
sensibles vous recommandations ont
remarqué me critique de la formation
d'alex ce soir de l'international en
dehors de la pique ou même de ses pairs
de l'union africaine et de la cedeao
fois les caves or le scrutin du 22 mars
une délégation de la cedeao de composer
les jours notamment de du président
ivoirien ouattara du nigeria souffre ou
du nigérian du harry du ghanéen akufo
addo
on parle quand même de quatre pays qui
sont parmi les plus importants les plus
puissants les plus influents de la sous
région devait se rendre en guinée pour
apaiser des choses impossibles discuter
que le président est bien libre dans
l'opposition le président a proposé une
fois à opposer une fin de non recevoir
caen prétextant la pandémie ducobu de 19
et pourtant il a quand même inscrit
donc on a un président qui aujourd'hui
est totalement isolé de même de la part
de ses pairs africains et plus les
choses avancent plus on sert d'isolant
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'il n'a
plus du tout d'interstices de dialogue
d'espagne dialogue entre l'opposition et
pouvoir y même avec les commentaires pas
rationnel et régionales alors vous
parlez de la cedeao il ya également
l'union africaine l'onu même qui sont
intervenus par rapport à la situation en
guinée
quelle est vraiment la marge de
manoeuvre de ces institutions pour
régler la situation
pour être vraiment et avec vous je pense
qu'elle est très limité les très limité
on ne peut pas parler de l'intervention
ce n'est pas raisonnable c'est même pas
justifiable
comme je viens de vous le dire la
faconde et a totalement refusé même
d'accueillir ses pairs africains dans
son pipe au moins discuter à minima avec
l'opposition
moi j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'en ce
moment se pose que ce qu'on est en train
de voir aujourd'hui c'est une répression
politique de tous les voix discordantes
les journées ce qui se font arrêter les
militants qui seront arrêtées aux est
fait référence à monsieur sékou diallo
qui en prison car activistes dont
l'achat de la démocratie enfin du matin
la constitution ce monsieur la cour
d'appel cour d'appel de conakry a décidé
de sa liberté provisoire et malgré tout
une encore en prison dont des tribunaux
qui rendent des jugement et cela ne
l'effraie pas le pouvoir il faut
absolument ce qu'il veut il ya d'autres
comtés manifeste la part du pouvoir de
se maintenir et de dire en gros je fais
ce que je veux et finalement cette
attitude ne fait que radicaliser
l'opposition qui désormais ne reconnaît
même plus les institutions le reconnais
ni le président de l'assemblée nationale
ni aucune institution là donc c'est un
bras de fer extrêmement dur d'entendre
jouer et ce qui est extrêmement grave
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de perspective pas
d'alternative qui puisse montrer qu'un
apaisement en fête puisse arriver
alors vous le disiez tout à l'heure
alpha condé n'a toujours pas clairement
dit s'il allait se présenter pour la
présidentielle ce sera au mois d'octobre
18 octobre et son parti justement va
tenir une convention le 5 août une
convention que très attendu justement
parce qu'on ne sait pas quel est le le
candidat du parti au pouvoir qui va se
présenter
qu'est-ce qu'on veut attendre pour cette
journée du 5 août en guinée je je je
pense qu'il faudrait attendre du tout il
faut juste attendre de savoir si
finalement c'est le président alpha
condé qui rappe sur la toile
à désigner et donc il ira pas un
troisième mandat
oui c'est quelqu'un d'autre mais je
pense que faut rien attendre de plus il
faut quand même rappeler une chose là le
dialogue est totalement rompu
extrêmement sale il y a eu en guinée un
référendum en mars 2000 20 mars dernier
22 mars
le texte qui a été promulguée le biais
de promotions de vulgarisation quelques
uns des articles de la presse reste à
l'international ce texte qui a été
présenté qui a été validé à 90% dans une
élection de chaotique parce qu'une
partie n'a pas boycotté et l'autre le
direct est un péché de voter ce texte a
été présenté ce n'est pas du tout le
même texte qui a été promulguée par le
président au jardin officiel vous avez
donc en fait deux fait un coup d'état
constitutionnel dans la mesure où le
texte qu'on vous présente n'est pas
celui qui allait arriver
et lorsqu'on demande l'édification de
l'état le mythe de la justice notamment
à aller devant la presse lundi entre le
texte qui a été promulguée et le texte
officiel
point à la ligne bleue circuler et le
texte que l'on consent 1-6 intéresse
c'est que la différence même nom à des
gothiques c'est quand même important
le nouveau texte qui est celui qui a été
homologué dans celui qui n'a pas été
présentée à vous la voie référendaire
contient des dispositions qui renforce
considérablement le pouvoir du président
alpha condé
il n'a quasiment plus aucune voie de
recours en cas de litige entre l'état et
une tierce personne ou une tierce
personne morale
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france monsieur ayant soigné sur
la pelouse est journaliste indépendant
merci